we need heroes
[Music]
I'm ready
Captain Marvel
effortless enigmatic fearless
talented refined iconic no thanks Bree
oh I was actually just talking about
this oh yeah
well yes Ozai
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie you guys may
have seen all the early Captain Marvel
reviews started rolling out so I'll
break everything down we also got a new
Avengers trailer sort of comparing her
origin to the origin of some of the
other Avengers characters and funny
goose the cat promo goose is definitely
one of the biggest things people came
out of the movie talking about so we'll
do an IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Captain Marvel
moment on the video these will all be
non spoilery so no worries about that
and I only be addressing things that
we've seen in the trailers or that the
actors have said publicly or Marvel has
released information about our Kevin
Feige so no worries there but you'll be
happy to know that the movie opens with
a very special Stan Lee tribute because
he did pass away but he had time to film
cameos for the next couple of Marvel
movies like he already shot his cameos
for spider-man far from home this summer
he shot cameos for Avengers endgame so
there is a lot of extra special Stanley
stuff going on there is a mid credit
scene and a post-credits scene so stay
the entire credits no surprise there is
the last movie building into Avengers
endgame so it's got the same task as
Black Panther did last year where you
have this relatively self-contained
origin story for the character here's
what her tone is like and here's how she
moves and feels differently from the
other Avengers but also here's all the
ways that she's connected to them and is
able to stand toe-to-toe with them in a
way that will enhance their presence
during avengers endgame when they're
fighting Thanos for the last time the
biggest difference between Captain
Marvel and the Black Panther movie last
year was that we had already gotten the
tutorial for Black Panther in Captain
America Civil War so you went into his
solo movie already knowing almost all
the biggest stuff about him Captain
Marvel kind of has to do all those
things while also showing her off for
the very first time so it's a very phase
one type of debut for a character like
when you met Thor for the first time
after seeing the Iron Man movies like oh
you see this hammer but you haven't seen
Chris Hemsworth as Thor before his solo
movie the tone of the film is very
classic 90s action film the directors
say they were mostly inspired by Robocop
in Terminator 2
Robocop not so much because of the tone
because it was like a really weird
alternate dystopian future but more
because of the storyline of post Robocop
Murphy trying to remember his past the
way the Captain Marvel loses her
Marie's after the accident that
activates her powers and she spends the
movie putting the pieces back together
the movie moves a little bit more like
the Terminator two movies so she's sort
of like an amalgam of a Kyle Reese and
Schwarzenegger Terminator character
advanced soldier claiming that she's
trying to stop this crazy space war that
Nick Fury person on the ground totally
doesn't believe at first until he sees
the proof of the scrolls with his own
eyes like Sarah Connor in the first
Terminator film or miles Dyson in
Terminator 2 pretty much everybody came
out of the movie being very surprised
about how the film wasn't what they
expected based on all the marketing in
the trailer so far which at this point
for Marvel movies shouldn't be that big
of a surprise but it's not like the big
Avengers movies there aren't any
straight-up
faked shots or false special effects
like fake Hulk in infinity war trailers
or anything like that it's not like
they're removing infinity gems out of
Captain Marvel suit or putting fake
characters in the background of shots or
anything like that so also in keeping
with the idea that the trailers don't
really convey the scope of the film in
its entirety the other really big
surprise was just how big in cosmic the
movie went like full blown space based
adventure guardians of the galaxy style
that all the clips don't really give you
a sense of like obviously you see Halle
the Kree homeworld a little bit but none
of the footage that they showed us do
any of that space based stuff justice so
if you're a really big fan of the cosmic
movies this goes full cosmic in a way
that'll make you really excited for what
they might do with future space based
Marvel movies and because of all the
delays with guardians of the galaxy 3 I
kind of assumed that they were gonna
lean into the more cosmic aspects of the
MCU with Captain Marvel but you just
don't see that in any other trailer so
it's kind of hard to tell until you go
and actually watch the movie itself the
sheer scope of those parts of the movie
also help answer a lot of the questions
that all the fans have asking about
where Captain Marvel's been this whole
time why has she been gone the last 20
years while the Avengers have been
dealing with all these big threats so
without giving away spoilers it will be
immediately evident just because of
what's going on in outer space why she
hasn't been around really happy to
report that Captain Marvel and may Fury
have great buddy-cop chemistry they'll
be fun and present day if they get some
scenes together during Avengers endgame
obviously you have to do a couple things
before that can happen because Nick
is currently a pile of ashes right now
so you have to bring him back but it
would be weird based on the way they set
up their story arc in the pager
post-credit scene during infinity war if
they don't have another short scene at
the end of Avengers endgame paying that
off
who's the cat and Ben Mendelsohn's Talos
scroll character steal the show not
surprised at all about gusta cat like
they have that funny clip of goose the
cat at the beginning of this the real
star of the movie oh I was talking about
gusta cat if you've seen any of the fan
art the last month you kind of get a
sense for how hyped up people are about
that cat so don't be surprised if they
try to bend over backwards at some point
and find a way to justify how that cat
is still around 20 years later in
present day so that they can put in the
Captain Marvel sequel the directors
actually said that early on when they
were still working on the script going
back and forth with the studio about
notes they only had a little bit of cat
in the movie in one of Kevin Feige G's
early really big notes was as I'm going
to need a hundred percent more of that
cat like that was literally what he said
so there's way more of the cat in the
movie that the trailers lit on like
there's obviously a couple of shots from
the movie in that cat promo where you
see it crawling around that drop ship so
if you read the comics it's not a
spoiler to say that the cat is not just
a simple earth cat you can get some of
the funny WTF moments that they use it
for like holy crap surprise but also
really funny stuff too I was a little
surprised by how much people love Talos
the scroll but Ben Mendelsohn is a great
actor most of you know him from Star
Wars rogue one I don't think that his
character during ready player one was
quite as good as his rogue one character
but he did a fantastic job with the
material
most of you already sensed the potential
of Scrolls within the MCU so you'd kind
of see the beauty of the way his
character works during the film and how
much fun then Mendelsohn has playing a
character like that the best thing I
could tell you to prepare for how much
fun that character is during the movie
is to reread marvel's Secret Invasion
comic book one of the best things about
that comic series is the nuance of how
the scrolls are written impersonating
the other big Avengers characters in the
comedy and the suspense of seeing those
really big characters that you love act
a little bit weird and not totally
knowing whether or not it's really them
or if it's a scroll impersonating them
so they use that to their full advantage
during the movie like they just turn Ben
Mendelsohn loose and he just runs with
it
and Marvel and Maria Rambo have a great
dynamic together both when she's Carol
Danvers before she gets her powers and
then later also after she gets her
powers I've already said how brie Larson
and the producers want to do miss Marvel
in the sequel so you have Miss Marvel
introduced in a Captain Marvel movie but
I would also not be surprised if they
try to bring back leshawna Lynch as
older Maria Rambo who maybe in the last
20 years has just rose through the ranks
in the air force to become a general of
sorts and her daughter Monica Rambeau
eventually gets powers like she does in
the comics and either becomes MCU Miss
Marvel if they want to swerve on Kamala
Khan or she becomes Photon
but because Kevin Feige did that
interview where he claimed that they
were planning on doing Kamala Khan miss
Marvel eventually that unless he says
something different between now and the
sequel officially starting production
I'm assuming that Monica Rambeau would
become the photon version of her comic
book character because photon is her
mother Maria Rambo's callsign so it
would make more sense that they pay off
that Easter Egg there are a couple of
the usual criticisms of Marvel movies
some of the 90s song choices felt a
little obvious and on the nose there
were a few moments in the film that just
felt a little out of place
pacing wise with the rest of the film so
really no different from say like Thor
Ragnarok or black panther like pretty
much all the Marvel movies have a lot of
the same criticisms I don't expect the
Captain Marvel movie to quite get the
same cultural appreciation that the
Black Panther movie got because it was
sort of like this alternative history
for an entire race of people that felt
very real for them very obtainable this
very aspirational look at a place that
felt very real
whereas Captain Marvel is largely
trading on 90s nostalgia and even though
like I said all the cosmic stuff in the
movie is really really cool that feels
very familiar to say like what you've
seen in Thor Ragnarok and the guardians
of the galaxy films so wasn't that quite
as relatable as the Wakanda of it all so
early prediction
Captain Marvel movie does around Thor
Ragnarok in Wonder Woman box office
numbers say like around 800 plus million
dollars but I don't think it's gonna
approach a billion dollars or more say
like the Black Panther movie just
because the response to that movie was
so over-the-top
the real lesson I think about Captain
Marvel is not to prematurely review a
movie just based on the marketing in the
trailers almost all Hollywood movies now
especially Marvel movies
being wildly different than the movie
that they sell you with all the trailers
so the end of the day it's a lot of fun
it provides a lot of connective tissue
between Avengers infinity war it sort of
recontextualizes the history of the MCU
during that period in the 90s which we
have not got before period films are
actually really fun so I am looking
forward to the Eternals movie which is
like the most period movie you could
possibly make because it's set eons ago
within the MCU the ancient history of
the MCU I know a lot of you are asking
what's going on with Coulson during the
movie they definitely have a lot of fun
with Clark Gregg so it is funny seeing
him back after being gone for so long
they've gotten so good with their D
aging technology that by the end of the
film you will completely forget that
samuel l.jackson is probably the same
age as your grandpa once you have a
chance to see the movie though let me
know in the comments what you guys think
about it and obviously once it does come
out everywhere we'll talk about post
credits scenes the ending of the movie
what's going on with her during Avengers
end game March and April are gonna be
crazy this year it's gonna be a lot of
fun so while you wait for everything
click here for all my Avengers endgame
trailer videos and Easter eggs
and click here for my brand-new
spider-man far from home trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]